the chance of mvp have already started
as they should
last home game
last chance to see shohei ohtani on the
mound at the big a
the american league mvp is in the house
shohei ohtani on his way to the mound
this man that mound this ballpark these
fans there is something special when
shohei pitches here
ohtoni
98
dials it up and down goes seeger yeah
for a very good fastball hitter and kyle
seeger may be thinking he's going to get
a split got the express
crawford at first
check swing wow that's a good pitch he
wins
ohtani gets the punch out
haniger goes down a pair of strikeouts
for ohtani and for marco he has really
really pitched well lately 23 starts on
the air looking to win his 10th game a
4-1-4 era
marsh not running ohtani hooks one
spinning throw out there and no chance
at first ty france makes a nice play
and ohtani replaces marsh at first base
for one
no oohing an eye on this one
toro
and that'll do it for the angels in the
first
here's the next pitch and
did he go after that one yes he did
struck him out
itani's racking up some strikeouts here
in the early going he gave up the
lead-off hit to crawford to start off
the game he's now retired the last five
in a row and three of those five
striking out
benjifo onto first
in time
johannatani two scoreless
big numbers against the mariners
good job by marco gonzalez his first
strikeout one down second inning
so here's suzuki who's been
picking up some hits lately he's hit
safely in six of his last seven games
kurt suzuki left field
how about that for a memory
kurt goes aloha
oh i'd love to see that
halo's up one up in his sixth
of the season
swinging the miss on a 2-2 pitch down
low that's the second strikeout for
marco that was the key with this change
if that one actually started on the
plate and that's how you're going to get
him to chase it
end of the bat and legarres wanders in
and makes the catch
one-two pitch
got him
[Applause]
punch out number 150
on the season for showtime
strike three call
90
under the hands
there's a nasty split looking 90 mile an
hour splitter
shohei that's the thing that's so
impressive when you watch shohei his
delivery almost every time he throws the
baseball rich it's the same delivery
3-2
show
12 retired in a row by ohtani
got him swinging
strikeout for marco a second out here in
the fourth inning his third strikeout
took a lot off of that
still giving a pretty good ride kelneck
easy play one two three marco
great stuff today just one blemish the
home run to suzuki it's quite the
pitchers duel that we anticipate
yes
got him 99
that's agent 99.
seven strikeouts he got smart
paints the corner 99
back up the middle base hit right past
ohtani off the bat of jared kellnick
into center field for a base hit
high fly ball
gosling again
got it
shohei ohtani
five shutout innings
here comes the pitch that is ball four
it missed low so a five pitch walk
3-1
and fletch walks
turns the line up over
now you've got marsh with two on
0-2 pitch
swing and a miss great job marco
gonzalez walks two they don't hurt him
leave him on the base paths one-nothing
angels let's see if kyle can figure him
out a couple strikeouts for kyle get
large in the first pitch
goes the other way there you go base hit
left field
first and second here come the mariners
with one out in the sixth
three two
eight strikeouts
three times
in this game it's the time where show
hey you can see him rubbing the baseball
he's going to gather his thoughts after
a tough at bat not a big lead at all by
france at second
toro in the air marsh is there
[Applause]
ohtani
six
shutout innies
for the mound of the batters box quick
transition shohei ohtani will lead it
off in the bottom of the sixth
cracked into center field that's a hit
that's helping yourself out
kept his hands back i really firmly
believe rich that pitching has helped
him out hitting this year because he's
able to realize certain pitches he's
able to stay focused and look what would
he be throwing there
the o2
swing and a miss marco makes quick work
of goslin
one two
number nine
three times he has struck out fraley
this afternoon yes now here is kelnen
here comes the 1-1
he hit it well deep right fifth genie up
going we got a tie ball game jk with a
home run is 14. it could not have come
at a better time mariners are tied up at
1-1
another one-two
[Applause]
that might have been his best
pitch of the day right there
there we are three two again
that's stung
to the gap
one hop
jp crawford lead off double top eight in
a one-one ball game
[Applause]
oh broken back jp's gonna get the third
it does
throw over to first figure save runners
up the corners what happened in the
eighth inning
one out and joe baden
goes to the bullpen again batters
batting just 179 against warren who is
yet to allow a home run this year he
faces hannigan with 2-1 j.p at third and
1-1
there is what we were looking for base
hit mitch haniger scoring his jp
crawford the mariners have a 2-1 lead in
the eighth inning
rbi for mitch is 88th in a big one
zorro right to the first baseman there
oh growth late high oh that works
everybody is safe for everybody moves up
90 feet
but now the bases are loaded and the
battery is left fielder jake fraley here
comes the 1-0 to jake
it's a deep left center field
and it's off the fence everybody runs
sega scores hannigan coming around
here comes toro and they've blown it
open here in the eighth inning
jake fraley clears the bases with a
double
and the mariners have a 5-1 lead
the o2 to suzuki
there it is that's it a strikeout and
the mariners win it 5-1 they finished
this road trip 8-2 and they closed down
the home season for the angels with a
big win a big win by the matters jared
kelnick a hero
you